[Musique]
c'est un peu noël avant l'heure pour
l'un des plus beaux villages de france
le maire de lièpvre le chatel a présenté
le projet de rénovation de l'église il y
à un peu plus d'un an et entre les
traces d'infiltration d'eau les murs
noircis et les fissures elle en avait
bien besoin
quand vous avez su alors elle commence
devant vous oui on en est toujours très
heureux on ne fait pas que les
opérations évidemment de cette ampleur
et il nous soulage un peu parce que
cette opération dans son ensemble a
coûté 800 mille euros hors taxes donc
lièvre à la ville es lièvre chatel c'est
au total 750 habitants c'est un budget
considérable pour une petite commune
petite commune qui attire malgré tout
cent mille visiteurs chaque année
construite au xième siècle l'église
saint go est le seul édifice à ne pas
avoir été restaurée plus vieux monument
du village sa rénovation fait le bonheur
de ses voisins
c'est une amie parce que je l'entends
comme on en parlait tout à l'heure je
l'entends sonné du matin au soir et du
soir au matin mais on finit par
s'habituer totalement alors quand on a
besoin savoir l'heure on tend l'oreille
et puis voilà c'est bon
à ce jour plus de 600 sites ont
bénéficié de la mission patrimoine
preuve de l'intérêt des français pour
ces monuments historiques c'est l'un des
plus beaux villages de france et enfin
que de voir ben l'église qui tombe comme
ça encore en ruine et qui s'abîme je
trouve que c'est malheureux même pour
nos enfants enfin on a déjà les choses à
leur montrer il faudrait peut-être les
conserver en fait
mais avant sa rénovation la direction
régionale des affaires culturelles
souhaite y faire des fouilles
archéologiques
les travaux ne devraient donc pas
débuter avant fin 2022